[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parle et sport c'est le deuxième numéro
de cette saison sur TV 78 au programme
aujourd'hui comme toujours des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau présentation en
musique de cette dream team on commence
à ma droite musique c'est une légende
vivante c'est un cycliste incroyable il
a déjà relié la France à la Chine en
vélo une autre fois il a passé plus de
24 heures sur un vélo sur la piste du
vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous pouvez
vous retourner Jean-Michel richefort
nous fait l'honneur de venir dans cette
émission bonjour comment allez-vous
Jean-Michel toujours en forme c'est un
plaisir de vous revoir sur cette
émission si vous avez fait plusieurs
émissions avec nous dernièrement mais si
on parlait sport depuis un petit moment
c'est vrai à peu près non voilà vous
avez gagné en expérience je ne sais pas
on va voir
on continue notre tour de table à gauche
musique vous reconnaissez sa musique les
journalistes chez TV 78 lui aussi une
légende un monument il connaît tout sur
le sport Illinois il est aussi un grand
fan du football italien notre italienne
lover notre tour de Pise Grégory canal
est avec nous pendant une heure pas
facile la tour de Pise qu'elle va rester
en place bonjour Michael bonjour
Jean-Michel comment allez-vous ecoutez
très bien à vrai dire même un petit coup
de mou sur ce début de saison mais on
dit que c'est à ce moment-là c'est
plutôt même sur le mois de novembre
qu'on va ressentir le travail qui a été
accompli durant l'été la petite
préparation physique normalement elle
devrait permettre de pouvoir repartir
sur une belle lancée en novembre voilà
vous allez vous allez me gratifier
encore d'une nouvelle envolée une
magnifique envolée dans quelques
instants j'ai eu la chance de la lire en
avant-première et elle est pas mal je
vous laisse la découvrir dans quelques
instants on termine de l'autre côté
musique les fans de ce tal que le
compare à George Clooney car il est
toujours élégant et il adore le café il
nous vient tout droit des antennes
contre Versailles une ville qui lui est
chère notre gladiateur Pierre Chevalier
du Rubik's cube de Versailles est avec
nous comment allez
bonjour les copains ça va très bien ça
va très bien en pleine forme
on est en face en face montante par
rapport à la préparation donc
effectivement les bienfaits de la
préparation estivale devrait se faire
sentir déjà c'est le cas on est passé à
travers
les deux mon général on est passé à
travers le covid et tout ça maintenant
on est en place la stratégie peut
s'appliquer en tout cas on embrasse
aussi à Jean-Mi c'est Yann Dujarier qui
n'ont malheureusement pas pu venir sur
cette émission on les retrouvera
évidemment sur les prochaines émissions
avant de passer au programme on va
parler football grosse déception pour le
FC Versailles le demi-finaliste de
l'édition 2022 a été éliminé par le Red
Star lors d'une terrible séance de tir
au but le score un partout et cinq tirs
buts à 4 pour le Red Star le club de
National pourra se consoler avec le
championnat ou les Versailles nous sont
pas trop mal avec une troisième place
cette élimination est-elle un choc pour
les versailler vous répondez oui ou non
comme d'habitude non oui non pour vous
pierre oui pour vous Grégory oui pour
vous Jean-Michel refaire un petit duel
entre eux Grégory et Pierre vous
commencez peut-être allez vous êtes seul
contre tous ouais voilà je dis habitué
on va dire
je dirais que ça n'est pas un choc parce
que après une saison comme comme la
saison dernière il n'est pas anormal ou
anodin de voir un petit peu une espèce
d'immense gueule de bois sur la
compétition qui nous intéresse sur la
Coupe de France sur la Coupe de France
pourquoi je dis que c'est pas c'est pas
forcément un choc c'est que le après
l'épopée de de 2022 avec cette
demi-finale de Coupe de France on a on a
vu on a débattu et on a pointé la
qualité de l'effectif versaillé qui
s'est renforcé à l'été à l'été 2022 que
le début de saison encourageant on en
parlait il y a il y a 15 jours sur le
sur ce plateau et sur les ambitions qui
sont pour l'instant pour l'instant au
rendez-vous avec avec au minimum le fait
maintien et puis peut-être plus si
l'appétit vient en mangeant mon propos
est de dire que on ne même en sport et
surtout en sport on ne peut pas
forcément courir plusieurs lieux vers la
fois et en l'occurrence
je pense que psychologiquement
le FC Versailles est passé sur un autre
plat sur un autre sur une autre
stratégie et sur une autre une autre
volonté qui est celle du championnat le
fait assumer de pouvoir se maintenir en
National de pouvoir bien y figurer
puisque là vous l'avez rappelé le début
de saison est plutôt plutôt encourageant
pour un promu parce qu'en plus la poule
de national cette division est quand
même assez relevée en termes en termes
d'équipe avec certaines équipes qui ont
qui ont même dérailler avec le plus haut
niveau donc tout ça pour dire que
ils sont passés à autre chose la case
Coupe de France épopée en Coupe de
France elle est presque elle est cochée
et maintenant ils sont concentrés sur le
championnat maintenant c'est vrai que
sur un huitième tour huitième tour 6e
tour de Coupe de France bon oui on
pouvait penser qu'après avec le scalp de
Toulouse le scalp de ceux de ceux qui
tombent l'OM etc
on pouvait attendre mieux que face à une
équipe comme le Red Star mais le Red
Star est aussi une bonne équipe de une
bonne équipe de coupe une bonne équipe
de championnats dans le championnat de
National de national donc c'est donc
c'est c'était
équitable comme comme opposition mais le
FC Versailles avait déjà je dirais
l'esprit l'esprit au championnat donc
pas forcément choqué Grégory il y a
beaucoup d'arguments du côté de Pierre
il monte en régime effectivement
on a envie de dire déjà la sixième tour
de Coupe de France on est dans les tous
premiers tours pour Versailles alors la
Coupe de France a commencé pour les
clubs amateurs au premier tour
Versailles ils sont passés presque à la
trappe sur le dernier tour il y avait eu
des grosses échauffourées sur un match
dans en Seine-Saint-Denis donc qui était
passé ils ont gagné 3 1 à la fin le
match
reprise donc il y a eu ce premier tour
pour Versailles qui était le 5e tour et
j'ai envie déjà de dire sixième tour
c'est c'est dommage quand on a vécu
l'épopée formidable de la saison
dernière jusqu'en demi-finale on
attendait au moins un petit à les 7e
voir 8e tour sur sur cette Coupe de
France voir peut-être affronter de
nouveau un club de Ligue 2 comme ils
avaient pu le faire l'année dernière
face à à Toulouse là il y a une petite
déception quand même à plusieurs titres
il y a une élimination face à une équipe
pensionnaire de la même division alors
ils ont pas eu forcément de chance au
tirage de prendre le Red Star des des
sixième tour l'élimination au tir au but
laisse un goût amer ils sont revenus
dans ce match ils étaient menés à zéro
ils ont réussi à revenir grâce à un but
contre son camp du Red Star le gardien a
du Red Star a été brillant et à stopper
la tentative du joueur Versailles dans
dans cette séance de tir au but donc
sixième tour oui ça laisse quand même un
goût d'image fait d'autant qu'en plus ce
match c'est jouer au stade Michel
Hidalgo il faut le rappeler parce que le
stade Montbron n'était pas disponible on
aurait pu voir un FC Versailles encore
une fois encore une fois ils auraient pu
revenir au stade Montbauron devant leur
public là c'est vrai que cette saison
bon il y a l'exil du côté de Paris je
rappelle que le stade Montbron n'est pas
encore homologué pour pour
des rencontres nationales et sous le
site de calendrier il y avait à ce
moment-là un gala de l'athlétisme à
Versailles et donc on n'a pas pu
forcément faire jouer cette équipe
Versailles donc il y a quand même un
petit goût de déception un goût
d'inachevé sur ce sixième tour on
attendait aller au moins 7e 8e tour pour
le FC Versailles je pense Jean-Michel
qui vous a convaincu mais moi je partage
les
les arguments de Grégory effectivement
deux équipes qui se valent deux qui sont
nationales le Red Star ce n'est pas
n'importe qui c'est une équipe avec de
l'expérience une équipe de de coupe et
après lorsqu'on arrive à la séance de
tir au but tout est tout est possible
c'est la loterie mais c'est quand même
une déception pour moi enfin voilà on
aurait aimé les voir poursuivre un peu
l'aventure Coupe de France qui est un
peu une marque de fabrique de Versailles
mais je pense qu'ils vont faire un très
bon championnat et maintenant voilà ils
vont se concentrer sur le championnat
mais les arguments de Grégory mon
convaincu en championnat en tout cas
c'est quatre victoires 3 nuits les deux
défaites pour 15 points engranger son
troisième un du championnat actuellement
pierre pour réconcilier tout le monde on
pourrait dire que justement cette cette
déconvenue serait bien vite oubliée si
le FCV se maintient et plutôt dans la
première moitié de tableau voilà on voit
le classement justement cette première
partie de tableau voilà troisième mais
on le disait la dernière fois c'est très
serré dans le championnat national on
rappelle que le 13e à partir de la 13e
place on descend dans le championnat
national 2 et vous voyez il y a trois
points d'écart avec avec la 12e place
donc tout est ouvert dans le championnat
de National aussi bien pour le positif
au Versailles mais on espère pas le
négatif en fin de saison
pour les super Jean-Michel
on en a parlé on en a parlé c'est le
sujet est posé pour l'instant personne
n'a tranché c'est sans doute un peu tôt
pour pour l'imaginer ou l'espérer sur
une première saison nationale alors nous
allons maintenant très rapidement
Yvelines en Coupe de France il y a un
septième tour pour les Poissy et
joueront contre le CSM noisetel qui est
une équipe de National 3 laisse Poissy
qui est en National 2 donc sur le tirage
potentiellement ça peut se faire et
laisse Poissy qui a éliminé une équipe
de national de également
Sainte-Geneviève donc il faut leur
rendre hommage c'est peut-être le petit
poucet youlinois de cette saison
derrière lequel on va être sur sur cette
saison de Coupe de France on espère
évidemment une demi-finale de Coupe de
France comme Versailles l'année dernière
contre Nice pourquoi pas ou une équipe
de Ligue 1 nous allons maintenant passer
au programme de l'émission aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de basket et du
prodige Victor web baniama les Vinois
affolent NBA nous parlerons également de
voile Louis Burton participera à la
Route du Rhum ce sera le 6 novembre
prochain et il veut performer les avant
de parler de cette thématique où on
parlait de cyclisme sur piste
[Musique]
on va revenir du coup dans cette
thématique sur les Championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste ils étaient
organisés du 12 au 16 octobre au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans Libye une
vraie répétition générale avant les Jeux
olympiques de 2024 sur la piste les
Tricolores sont sont plutôt bien sortis
avec trois médailles d'or 3 médailles
d'argent et une médaille de bronze on
l'écoute le DTN de la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme Christophe main au
micro de TV 78 on est toujours sur cette
stratégie de pas annoncer de de
d'objectif de médaille mais on sait là
où on est médaillable par rapport au
résultat passé aux résultats dans les
coupes du monde donc là on a eu il y a
eu des disciplines où on pensait qu'on
était médaillable et ça s'est mal passé
puis on a eu aussi d'autres surprises où
on pensait pas qu'on y serait donc voilà
ça a compensé je pense deux pour deux
alors pour l'or il y a eu la médaille
d'or de Mathilde de gros sur la vitesse
individuelle la médaille d'or de Marie
divine coimée sur le 500 mètres et l'or
sur le madison homme avec le duo Donavan
Grondin Benjamin Thomas pour l'argent il
y a eu Melvin Landerneau sur le
kilomètre une médaille d'argent sur le
Madison femme avec Clara Coconi du club
local du vaisseau Sky Team vous sers et
l'argent avec Benjamin à Thomas sur
l'Omnium enfin il y a la médaille de
bronze en poursuite par équipe la
question sur cette thématique le bilan
de ces Mondiaux est-il bon pour la
France sur la piste et dans les tribunes
il y a encore du boulot à faire bon il y
a bien sûr des petits une déception en
vitesse par équipe ou là bon il y a eu
un faux départ qui a perturbé donc notre
équipe et puis bien sûr vitesse par
équipe masculine et donc avec télévision
du team du team vous sert 50 ans et demi
local et qui est le le petit jeune de
cette équipe mais c'est ce qu'il a quand
même il a tout juste 20 ans mais c'est
une équipe une équipe qui normalement
pouvait jouer la médaille d'argent voir
une médaille de bronze sans aucun
problème ils ont toujours été médaillés
je vous rappelle les les Français voilà
c'est la petite déception en vitesse
individuelle la chute de Sébastien
Vigier qui est quand même le leader des
des sprinters la chute
dans dans sa demi-finale de kering et
après la ligne d'arrivée dans le virage
juste après
pour la vitesse individuelle voilà là
c'est le mais ça peut arriver bien sûr
malheureusement mais cela dit oui c'est
un bilan positif et plein de promesses
pour les pour les échéances à venir
Grégory
on en parlait avec Jean-Michel sur
splato lundi dans Le 7 8 jeunesse c'est
la jeunesse qui est aussi brillée de la
jeunesse qu'on attendait on a mis la
pression sur une Mathilde de gros depuis
de nombreuses années elle l'a supporté
sur ses mondiaux elle a réussi à
emporter l'or sur la vitesse
individuelle et des jeunes qu'on
n'attendait pas forcément on a parlé de
Marie divine Kwame c'est aussi l'un des
gros gros sourires sur sur ces cinq
jours de compétitions
en tout cas on va l'écouter en interview
alors on va l'entendre dans quelques
instants
son maître c'est incroyable ça promet
pour la suite je suis tellement fière je
pensais jamais ressentir ce genre
d'émotion et c'est un croix viable je le
souhaite à tous les sportifs du monde je
le souhaite à même les non sportive de
ressentir ça à la fierté des parents la
fierté de la famille des amis de
l'équipe du coach de tout le monde et
voilà je suis trop contente
j'ai envie de dire heureusement qu'il y
a eu le week-end pour sauver ces
Mondiaux parce que Jean-Michel le
rappeler ça a commencé sur un faux
départ presque il y avait vraiment eu un
faux départ pour la vitesse par équipe
homme et il y a eu des déceptions il y a
aussi la poursuite homme par équipe avec
les nations en quart de finale on
attendait aussi de cette équipe de
France qui est championnat d'Europe qui
était champion d'Europe à Munich l'été
dernier et là le week-end qui est venu
sauver j'ai envie de dire c'est même pas
les meubles qui est venu carrément même
rendre cette compétition réussie aussi
bien dans le public on a eu un vélo de
Rome qui a été plein qui a fait le plein
5000 personnes par jour sur les journées
de samedi et dimanche et des médailles
d'or Mathilde de gros le vendredi sur la
vitesse individuelle femme qui a fait la
une de l'équipe le samedi Mary divine
Kwame pleine de fraîcheur le le samedi
et Grondin et Thomas sur sur le dimanche
donc on a très très bien terminé c'est
c'est mondiaux et c'est de bonne augure
j'ai envie de dire pour parler 2024
Pierre Chevalier Mathilde de gros c'est
peut-être l'image peut-être de ces
championnats du monde Mathilde de gros
en larmes après tout ce qu'elle a vécu
ces dernières années on l'a pas mal
critiqué il faut le dire sur ce plateau
en disant que c'est voilà on attend on
attendait tellement en fait de de
Mathilde de gros sur ces dernières
échéances là ça y est elle brille je me
souviens surtout de de la présentation
qu'on en a fait et ce depuis qu'elle est
passée du basket au vélo j'ai entendu
après son après son titre le le
l'histoire justement l'histoire de de sa
découverte sur un sur un One bike à un
entraînement de basket qui fait dire qui
fait dire un spécialiste je sais pas
s'il était membre des équipes de France
ou de l'encadrement
cette petite est là elle a elle a du
elle a de la puissance dans les jambes
il faudrait il faudrait qu'elle
rencontre quelqu'un chez quelqu'un chez
nous et elle et elle passe effectivement
Greg parlait de pression mais moi je
pense que c'était surtout des attentes
finalement de cette OVNI là on parle
d'OVNI au rugby c'est peut-être aussi un
ovni un ovni dans le monde dans le monde
du vélo et ce que j'ai trouvé
fantastique vous connaissez moi mon
amour pour le vélo et donc je vais
essayer je vais essayer de donner une
une émotion de spectateur parce que
c'est la première fois que grâce à la
médiatisation de ces titres là je suis
un petit peu de confronté à la l'Inter
timing du vélo et j'ai trouvé les deux
réactions de ces champions parce que ce
qui est génial aussi c'est ces deux
femmes qui gagnent ces deux femmes qui
gagnent dans un dans un milieu où c'est
souvent les hommes qui qui performaient
notamment aux JO et
avec Greg Greg Baugé par exemple et
c'est deux c'est deux femmes
Mathilde et Marie divine quel prénom
ce sourire là et cette enthousiasme à un
an des à deux ans des JO c'est
absolument fantastique donc je retiens
que c'est cette histoire cette histoire
fantastique d'une responsabilité assumée
par Mathilde gros et ça énormément coûte
chapeau d'être là au rendez-vous là où
personne ne se prononcer finalement tu
l'as appelé ni les ni les ni
l'encadrement ni nous ni nous les
observateurs extérieurs sur ce plateau
ne nous prononcions sur les chances de
médailles françaises c'est là aussi on
se mouillait pas beaucoup à l'époque et
force est de constater que le bilan est
positif avec ses notamment ces deux
titres plus les autres qui ont suivi
malgré les déceptions de ce qu'on
attendait notamment les garçons et c'est
je pense c'est un une note d'espoir
fantastique pour pour le vélo pour la
capacité des équipes de France de
réussir leur JO en 2024 et
particulièrement dans ce dans ce vélo
Drôme de Saint-Quentin dont on parle
souvent et là qui a vibré et qui
qui a fait qui a fait de ces
championnats du monde une répétition
générale de Paris 2024 juste pour le
plaisir on va peut-être réécouter la
réaction de Mathilde de gros qui a fait
la une de l'équipe en Russie le
lendemain on va justement l'écouter
incroyable c'est vraiment un rêve
chanter la marseillais devant mon public
devant sur ma piste dans notre Vélodrome
enfin nous toute l'équipe de France on
s'entraîne ici donc c'est pour tous les
autres athlètes pour tout le staff pour
la fédé c'est vraiment ouais c'est pour
eux quoi c'est c'est top c'est je
pouvais pas rêver mieux ce soir
Jean-Michel sur ma piste assez approprié
sa piste du vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et là c'est
très fort mais pour revenir un peu en
arrière effectivement on en a fait
peut-être une une grande championne
avant l'heure il fallait la laisser
mûrir parce que elle n'a pas fait elle
n'a pas fait d'école de de cyclisme donc
quand on vient d'un sport et puis même
avec des qualités exceptionnelles
vous l'avez rappelé mais il y a un
apprentissage il y a la technique il y a
de l'expérience à acquérir donc
n'oublions pas elle a été championne
d'Europe à la mairie mais on l'attendait
trop vite et faut laisser mûrir là elle
a pris une dimension supérieure et je
pense que maintenant aller sur la bonne
trajectoire pour égaler Félicia
Ballanger à n'oublions pas qui a été
multiple championne du monde championnat
olympique également c'est un modèle
aussi et là elle est bien partie sur les
sur les traces de Félicia je pense que
on la reverra avec plaisir aux JO dans
deux ans dernière question peut-être sur
cette thématique des Championnats du
Monde est-ce que l'événement est réussi
et surtout est-ce qu'il faut améliorer
les choses peut-être sur pour ces JO de
2024 qui seront dans ce lieu de national
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines parce que
c'est terminé maintenant on parle de
l'après je pense je pense sincèrement
que c'est réussi parce que en tant que
là encore une fois spectateur extérieur
à ce sport que je regarde assez peu
toucher aux propres et aux figuré par
notamment par cette cette fraîcheur dans
l'équipe de France féminine notamment et
avec ces deux titres et j'ai trouvé dans
les images les nombreuses images qu'on a
vu parce que ça a été l'occasion de
médiatiser encore un peu plus le vélo le
cyclisme sur piste
surprise agréablement surpris par le
monde qui avait dans les dans les
travées du Vélodrome pour une fois
n'était pas forcément plein mais mais
sur les premiers jours mais après
c'était soldat out complet sur vendredi
samedi dimanche sur ce sur ce point de
vue là répétition générale sur ce qui
justement ce qui ce qu'il faut continuer
à faire ou ne pas faire et puis et puis
un élan populaire qui qui promet pour
2024 ça promet pour 2024 est-ce qu'il
faudra peut-être améliorer des choses à
votre avis les organisateurs disent
qu'il faut travailler encore sur la
sécurité parce que aussi sur cet
agglomération de 50 ans en ligne il y
aura plusieurs sites olympiques beaucoup
plus de monde aussi à accueillir avec le
golf nationale le VTT sur la colline et
aussi balle BMX ont toujours sur ce site
du vélo drone donc même sur le site du
Vélodrome on aura aussi bien le cyclisme
sur piste et le BMI qui aura aussi le
pentathlon moderne les Scream du
pentathlon moderne au vélo de Rome donc
c'est un événement d'une autre ampleur
avec peut-être d'autres priorités
d'autres on va dire problématiques mais
en tout cas peut-être sur la sécurité
c'est ce qui est ressorti dans les
discussions avec les organisateurs là ça
sera complet tous les jours sur sur les
Jeux Olympiques Jean-Michel peut-être
quelque chose à améliorer la connexion
internet apparemment pour les
journalistes oui bon après ce sont des
détails mais bien sûr ça aussi l'accès
l'accès peut-être les les parkings mais
ce sera ce sera je pense résolu d'ici là
parce qu'il faut réfléchir à toute à
tous les paramètres lorsqu'on organise
les Jeux olympiques mais bon déjà les
équipes de la Fédération vont travailler
avec les équipes du Kojo pour peaufiner
donc cet accueil dans au sein de ce vélo
drone le Stadium de BMX et puis la
Élancourt le but de la revanche à
Élancourt tout ça devrait être au top
pour les JO pour la piste il parle
également de créer du spectacle aussi
autour de ces Jeux Olympiques avec
peut-être des engins pyrotiques une
lumière qui s'abaisse au moment des
finales est-ce que vous pensez que ça
peut être une bonne option c'est Nicolas
André qui nous a confié ça il travaille
à Fédération Française de scie sûrement
sûrement de toute façon tout ce qui sera
un plus pour n'oublier pour mettre en
valeur les athlètes notamment donc
baisser un peu le la lumière dans les
tribunes mettre éclairé éclairer la
piste enfin avec des jeux n'oublions pas
que ce sera télévisé dans le dans le
monde entier et là effectivement il y a
sûrement une mise en scène à peaufiner
et qui sera déjà on le verra
prochainement lors de la Champions
League fin novembre où là il y aura
aussi une belle une belle mise en scène
où les organisateurs on se savoir faire
mais oui il y a des détails à améliorer
mais cela dit dans les grandes lignes
ces championnats du monde ont été une
belle répétition pour les JO Pierre
Chevalier très rapidement une dernière
une dernière réaction d'émotion j'ai
noté dans les réactions et les
interviews de Marie divine et de
Mathilde la référence à leur famille et
justement quand elle se jette quand
Mathilde de gros se jette dans les bras
de je pense sa maman et de sa famille
avec une émotion submergée
à sa famille et qui souhaitent tout ça à
tous les sportifs du monde c'est c'est
aussi prometteur en espérant que que la
famille France 2024 et que toutes les
équipes de France puissent être
mobilisés à ce point pour les JO à Paris
on va maintenant passer à notre envolée
du jour avec vous Grégory c'est toujours
le un moment qui plaît aux
téléspectateurs de TV 78 c'est à vous il
y a un athlète qui a attiré votre
attention sur ces Mondiaux Grégory et il
n'est pas français évidemment j'ai envie
de dire avec le tas de quelle
nationalité est-il slovaque Jean Michel
je n'ai aucune idée italienne
je vais vous parler de Philippot Gana
celui que l'on a renommé de l'autre côté
des Alpes sous terre people il a une
fois de plus brillé sur ces champs
et ce n'était pas gagné pour Ghana elle
était facile celle-là mais il est arrivé
fatigué sur ces mondiaux de cyclisme sur
piste on en reparlera tout à l'heure on
évoquera pourquoi et le coureur de la
INEOS de 26 ans a même plutôt déçu sur
le début il faut le dire avec la
squadrazzura championne olympique et du
monde entier de la poursuite par équipe
il n'a pas réussi à se transcender Pipo
n'a pas été impressionnant final contre
la Grande-Bretagne il a gagné aucun
dixième sur ses adversaires au moment où
c'était lui qui menait à l'Italie
résultat une deuxième place une médaille
d'argent ça c'était jeudi et on se dit à
ce moment là que le Transalpin n'est pas
dans son assiette que de ce sera pas sa
semaine à 50 ans en Yvelines mais
c'était mal le connaître mal connaître
ce double champion du monde de
contre-la-montre quadruple champion du
monde de la poursuite quadruple quand il
est arrivé bien sûr dans les Yvelines
puisque le lendemain Philippe éclaboussé
le vélo Drôme de sa classe et de son
talent face à son compatriote et
Jonathan Millan l'athlète a remporté une
cinquième médaille d'or dans sa carrière
en poursuite individuelle encore mieux
il a battu le record du monde détenu par
l'américain Ashton Lamby avec son chrono
de 359 636 un exploit incroyable c'est
le premier coureur de l'histoire à
passer sous la barre des quatre secondes
au niveau de la mer 4 minutes 4 secondes
c'est très c'est très court 4 minutes au
niveau de la mer merci Jean-Michel pour
ce petit ce petit lapsus de me l'avoir
signalé alors on a pu recueillir ça
réaction c'est avec Mélanie poquet le
matin de sa performance écoutez-le Gana
ne voulait même pas s'aligner sur cette
compétition regardez
aujourd'hui ça a été l'une des journées
les plus intenses que j'ai vécues
c'est un matin
à 10h30 je ne voulais pas faire la
poursuite je voulais mettre fin à ma
saison voilà je voulais partir en
vacances et après mes coéquipiers sont
arrivés
ce qui est en bord piste pour
m'encourager me dire que je pouvais le
faire
je dois leur dire merci d'avoir cru en
moi et de m'avoir donné confiance donc
merci à eux merci à tout le public aussi
qui était ici vraiment chaleureux merci
vraiment car quand j'ai compris que je
pouvais le faire battre ce record du
monde eux aussi m'ont donné la greinta
l'énergie pour y arriver donc merci
le petit merci en français vous l'aurez
noté à la fin de à l'intérieur
rappelez-vous je vous disais tout à
l'heure que Philippe pogana est arrivé
sur ces Mondiaux fatigués et pour cause
le samedi d'avant c'était le 8 octobre
Pipo s'emparer du record du monde de
l'heure en parcourant 56 km 792 sur la
piste de grande en Suisse il a effacé la
marque de 55 km 548 réalisé en août
dernier par son propre ingénieur Daniel
bigame il détient déjà depuis l'an passé
avec ses coéquipiers également un autre
record celui du monde sur la poursuite
par équipe alors en 5 jours on l'a vu
donc c'est pas un c'est deux records du
monde avec cet adjugé l'italien
stratosphérique à qualifier la Gazzetta
dello Sport c'est l'équivalent de
l'équipe en Italie c'est le principal
quotidien sportif italien Philippo Gana
c'est même payé le luxe d'être en une le
lendemain alors il fait pas la grosse
une comme Mathilde de gros mais vous
voyez sur le côté droit on voit top
Ghana qui a donc remporté cette médaille
d'or et ce record du monde à la
poursuite individuelle il est un
extraterrestre de sa discipline mais qui
garde les pieds sur terre en parlant
avec lui Michael j'ai le sentiment d'un
homme simple très sympathique qui rêve
des JO de 2024 il se voit pas encore aux
JO lui dit je croise les doigts pour
être de cet échéance en 2024 petit
souvenir de nos mondiaux d'ailleurs
Michael ce petit selfie réalisé c'était
un grand plaisir de le rencontrer
Philippe au Ghana voilà c'est un peu la
classe à l'italienne oui je vous avoue
que moi aussi enfin j'ai pris du plaisir
à pas le voir en tout cas et cette
petite photo le montre bien évidemment
alors la question sur cette thématique
tout simplement ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec Grégory est-ce que c'est
la classe à l'italienne ce Pipo Ghana
alors qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
Jean-Michel oui bien sûr c'est la classe
c'est la classe à l'état pur mais on
était en droit de se poser des questions
parce qu'il a fait un tour de France
moyen il ne faisait pas imposé sur les
chronos du tout
après au championnats du monde et bien
il a été battu une nouvelle fois donc
c'était pas dans ses habitudes et là on
se posait des questions alors est-ce
qu'il était réellement programmé on peut
le croire pour son record de l'heure le
record de l'heure n'oublions pas que sa
performance elle est quand même
exceptionnelle il a peut-être battu son
ingénieur mécanicien mais l'ingénieur
mécanicien en question ce n'est pas
n'importe qui c'est un titulaire de
l'équipe de Grande-Bretagne donc et qui
était au championnat du monde également
qui était dans l'équipe qui a été
championne du monde de poursuite par
équipe donc voilà on dit oh oui sur
mécanicien
c'est vraiment un très grand mais voilà
on pouvait se poser des questions il
était programmé il était à l'heure avec
un record du monde en descendant en
dessous des 4 minutes
sur cette piste de ces 50 ans ouais
c'est tout à fait exceptionnel mais
c'est la marque d'un très grand voilà
très grand et sur le vélo et en dehors
de vélo très grand la classe la
simplicité le sourire il donne envie
Pierre Chevalier la classalité
le plus italien des chroniqueurs de
sport français de l'avoir fait découvrir
avec ce petit accent en plus qui vous
scier si bien et oui a priori il fait
partie des de la classe des de la classe
des seigneurs et en plus de quand il est
pas attendu ou quoi tu dois pas trop
envie bah un petit record du monde ou un
titre ça a l'air facile son vélo coûte
60 000 euros il est imprimé en 3D
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Pierre
Chevalier je me prends une bagnole moi
pour ça moi aussi
Grégory il dépasse peut-être aussi le
cadre de son sport j'ai l'impression
qu'en Italie on l'aime beaucoup on
l'aime beaucoup en Italie alors on est
des grands fans de les Italiens sont des
grands fans de cyclisme c'est vrai que
le sport roi en Italie c'est le football
mais à côté de ça les sports mécaniques
et le cyclisme aussi large place et dès
qu'il y a des résultats italiens dans
ces sports même dans les autres formes
mais particulièrement sur ses sports ils
occupent facilement les unes des
journaux le lendemain la Gazzetta le
lendemain alors on aurait pu peut-être
espérer il y a une sur le foot italien
mais pour ce titre et ce record du monde
on aurait pu espérer peut-être une large
une mais c'est aussi comprendre quelle
place occupe ce sport le football en
Italie mais le cyclisme aussi toute sa
place dans le cœur des Italiens merci à
Grégory en tout cas pour cette
magnifique envolée comme d'habitude été
spectateurs sont ravis j'en suis sûr le
prochain grand rendez-vous Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en ligne ce sera
Lucie Champion's League le 26 novembre
vous en avez parlé juste avant
Jean-Michel et il y aura bien sûr un
départ des cours du Tour de France aussi
l'été prochain devant l'enlever le drone
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
vous l'aurez compris un vélo de route
pas vraiment au coeur du cyclisme c'est
à prochains mois en passe maintenant à
notre page débat
[Musique]
dans cette page débat on va parler de
basket il impressionne déjà le monde de
la NBA livinois Victor au Wemba nyama
originaire du Chesnay à discuter deux
matchs outre-Atlantique avec son équipe
de Boulogne Levallois il a brillé en
inscrivant plus de 30 points dans deux
matchs face à des équipes de Jelly
League la Ligue américaine mineur
l'ancien
mvprose pense que Wendy deviendra un
modèle la star LeBron James a dit que
c'était un extraterrestre la pépite de
Boulogne Levallois encore performé
également lors du dernier match de son
club avec 24 points 9 rebonds deux
contre et une interception la question
sur cette thématique est-ce qu'il faut
s'enflammer oui ou non vous votez est-ce
qu'il faut s'enflammer entre les deux
oui pour vous Jean-Michel alors pourquoi
vous êtes entre les deux parce que je le
répète sans cesse les sons grandir les
jeunes dans le calme je rappelle qu'il y
a 18 ans il a 18 ans on parle toujours
de ses performances mais c'est vrai que
il se met de plus en plus en lumière
cette date fatidique de 2023 avec cette
première place annonce à la draft se
rapproche on parle même des des
éventuels clubs des éventuels franchises
qui pourraient s'ajuger Victor
webmaniament on parle des Yuta jazz
normalement notamment aux États-Unis
mais maintenant j'ai envie de le voir
grandir c'est vrai que l'année dernière
est sorti d'une saison il était plutôt
blessé on l'a pas vu forcément donner on
va dire montrer tout son talent à Las
veulent il était à Nanterre avant il a
fait l'ASVEL l'année dernière las
veulent de Tony Parker bien sûr et donc
cette saison métropolitaine 92 à
Boulogne Levallois il commence
tranquillement il commence
tranquillement il a de il affole les
stats il a plusieurs photos notamment
avec une avec Mbappé je sais pas si on
l'a mais on voit toute sa grandeur c'est
2 mètres 21 et on fera un petit point
croissance je pense à chaque fois qu'on
parlera de Victor web benyama pour voir
on l'a vu il était à 2,16
maintenant voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai
pas un peu comme les enfants en fait on
les voit grandir au fur et d'un côté
j'ai pas envie de m'enflammer parce
qu'il a encore jeune et j'ai pas envie
qu'il se grille et qui grille les étapes
avant et bien de faire le
tremplin on va dire final en NBA
maintenant c'est vrai que quand on
regarde les stats et quand on regarde
ses performances sur le terrain on voit
aussi qui commence à prendre un peu en
musculature c'est ce qu'on redoutait
peut-être les blessures il est très long
génie très très fin il commence à
prendre un petit peu plus d'ampleur donc
j'ai envie de dire c'est vrai qu'on peut
aussi s'enflammer parce qu'il commence
de fort belles manières cette saison
pierre sur TV 78 on le couvre on le
couvre ce petit ce petit depuis
longtemps ce petit de mes 19 2m21 de
mètres 22 enfin il continue à grandir on
le couvre depuis longtemps là où je
m'enflamme un peu c'est que je dis que
le temps sportif est un temps court et
que ça fait déjà ça fait déjà deux ans
trois ans qu'on en parle depuis qu'il
est depuis qu'il est arrivé à Nanterre
après son passage à Boulogne Levallois
et donc il est il a il a déjà un peu
d'expérience alors ok en pro en proie et
et dans les et dans les divisions
inférieures de jeunes mais il a déjà il
a déjà roulé roulé sa bosse sur les
parquets
au tout début sur ce plateau en disant
ne le grillon pas laissons-le maturer
notamment notamment physiquement et là
il a l'air de prendre le chemin bon il
fait il fait entre guillemets que 95 kg
pour ces 2 mètres 19 21 et quelques donc
c'est pas encore un golgot
à l'échelle de la NBA mais il en prend
gentiment le chemin et donc là là on
peut on peut s'enflammer avec douceur et
avec bienveillance pour ce pour ce jeune
joueur en lui souhaitant la meilleure
place dans la prochaine draft de NBA et
les meilleurs basketteurs américains
s'enflamment pour lui LeBron James
LeBron James ce qui est pour certains le
successeur de Michael Jordan qui a gagné
nombreux titres en NBA dit de lui que
c'est un extraterrestre on peut
s'enflammer Jean-Michel quand même mais
on peut s'enflammer oui moi je suis
vraiment
pour juger le basket en tout cas il sait
tout faire c'est ça qu'il faut retenir
l'huile c'est tout faire sur le parquet
alors que d'autres étaient plus
spécialisés lui il est il sait tout
faire
trois points quand il a gagné contre une
équipe américaine alors que logiquement
vu sa taille
il devrait être dans la raquette si je
peux dire c'est ça c'est ce qui fait un
peu qui sont
sans statut d'extraterrestre mais bon il
a quand même tout approuvé encore alors
bien sûr les meilleures équipes vont se
lâcher et tout j'espère qu'il gardera
bien la tête sur les épaules mais bon
c'est c'est un grand c'est un grand
c'est évident
voilà voilà moi je suis toujours
admiratif devant c'est c'est sportif qui
sortent de l'ordinaire ce qui passe
petit à petit dans une autre dimension
on disait déjà les prospects américains
étaient sur lui dès la saison dernière
là déjà aux États-Unis on a même pas
commencé la saison NBA on est déjà en
train de dire en quel club il va aller
la saison prochaine on s'enflamme
énormément en France mais on s'enflamme
aussi de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
donc on va voir on va voir bien sûr
qu'on est super heureux de le voir enfin
éclore on a parlé de son talent de son
potentiel là enfin ils sont talent
éclaboussent la France et que la bouse
les États-Unis donc on va lui souhaiter
tout le meilleur le basketteur Jenny
antéo compo a dit tous les joueurs
ressembleront à Wemba nyama en 2045 il
impose une nouvelle norme grand et
surtout hyper polyvalent vous êtes
d'accord Pierre Chevalier j'aurais pas
eu cette eugénisme là mais en tout cas
il dit que c'est le futur tout
simplement le grand
sportifs sur un sport plus proche de moi
sur au rugby notamment les les jeunes
qui qui éclosent maintenant en ce moment
en U18 ou U20 sont sur des courbes de
croissance effectivement qu'on avait pas
qu'on n'avait pas notre époque au siècle
dernier et qui qui semble qui semble
prouver que élever au grain comme ça
effectivement on va avoir des des
sérieux athlètes et il doit aller en NBA
dès cette année on est d'accord oui ton
cours
bien sûr et moi j'aimerais
pour le coup il sera sous l'effet des
projecteurs
plus qu'en France tous les moyens pour
pour performer et pour et pour continuer
à continuer à se bâtir un physique de
déménageurs et moi j'espère le voir en
équipe de France rapidement c'est
peut-être le plus c'est lui qui
sélectionner
pré-convocation Grégory doit y aller dès
cette année
en 2023 c'est tout le mal qu'on peut lui
souhaiter moi j'espère juste qu'il va
pouvoir conserver son entourage on sait
qu'autour de lui sa famille c'est un
entourage très sain je sais pas si ça a
fallu pour le suivre aux États-Unis mais
c'était aussi l'une de ses forces et on
disait on l'a bercé on l'a couvé même et
j'espère qu'on pourra pas le faire
grandir aussi tranquillement une billet
sera plus compliqué il sera un peu plus
exposé qu'en France on suivrait
évidemment avec attention les
performances de wembi dans les prochains
mois et on en démore pas on veut la voir
l'interview avant un départ aux
États-Unis chez tes tv78 sur ce plateau
je ne pense pas mais en tout cas en
extérieur avoir une interview avec lui
d'ailleurs euh on n'a pas la place sont
trop petites chez nous ce sera peut-être
l'une des dernières occasions de le voir
jouer en France avec un club avec
l'équipe de France peut-être pas mais il
faut se presser pour aller le voir avec
les Métropolis on va maintenant parler
d'un autre sportif yvelinois de haut
niveau mais cette fois-ci en voile Louis
Burton repart pour de nouvelles
aventures le skipper originaire de
Rambouillet va participer le 6 novembre
prochain à la Route du Rhum 2022 un
rendez-vous où il visera un top 5 sur
son bureau Vallée 3 on écoute Louis
Burton au micro de TV 78 j'ai été dans
le top 5 une cinquième place en 2014 en
classe immoca donc j'aimerais bien
pas faire moins bien que ça quoi mais
bon il faut déjà terminer c'est c'est
une composante importante terminée une
course et puis du coup gérer la zone
rouge pas cassée et viser la meilleure
place à l'arrivée moi j'ai une top
équipe qui me suit
pour le bateau Bureau Vallée depuis
plusieurs années donc on a essayé de
penser à tout ça c'est vraiment
important et puis après ben c'est une
histoire de calibration de pas pousser
trop loin dans la zone rouge et limiter
les risques de casse il faut un peu de
réussite un peu de chance parce que
c'est un sport mécanique au milieu des
éléments donc il peut se passer plein de
choses
Louis Burton est en pleine préparation
pour le Vendée Globe 2024 il veut
évidemment performer sur cette route du
Rhum La question sur cette thématique
Louis Burton a-t-il une obligation de
résultats sur cette route du Rhum oui ou
non vous votez
obligation non pour vous pierre non pour
vous Jean-Michel non pour vous Grégory
pourquoi Grégory obligation non après
que ça puisse le mettre en confiance en
vue de ce Vendée Globe 2024 qu'on attend
tous avec impatience après sa troisième
place lors de la dernière édition oui
forcément on se souvient sur une
dernière grosse course c'est la Transat
il y a deux ans maintenant c'était fin
2021 enfin
j'ai déjà envie de passer à 2023
on a vu bah qui c'est pas c'est pas une
déception mais nous on a été déçu de son
abandon très précoce sur une course où
il était en duo il faut le rappeler
aussi avec son son nouveau bureau Vallée
on attendait aussi qu'il puisse
performer sur cette course parce que
c'était après le Vendée Globe la
première grosse course avec son nouveau
bateau maintenant là il repart on est à
2 ans du Vendée Globe obligé de de
performer non mais forcément il faut pas
qu'il casse il faut pas qu'il abandonne
et qu'il casse son mât comme la dernière
fois des dès les premiers jours c'est
aussi un paramètre de chance à prendre
en compte on verra si il mettre chance
avec lui mais il peut se mettre sur très
bon rail j'ai envie de dire en vue de ce
Vendée Globe 2024 maintenant en
performant et en finissant cette course
de la Route du Rhum pierre qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je suis je suis avec
attention depuis nombreuses années aussi
des athlètes yvelinois que dont on parle
souvent sur ce plateau obligation
d'accord avec Greg non parce que il l'a
rappelé c'est un sport mécanique on l'a
vu sur le sur le Jacques Vabre l'année
dernière à quel point c'est ses athlètes
que j'appellerai hors du commun malgré
tout parce que c'est il faut quand même
se le fader cette cette traversée quelle
qu'elle soit avec avec un seul seul à la
barre d'un bateau comme celui-là et on
avait vu et on avait vu à quel à quel
point une casse aussi
inattendue imprévisible l'avait lui
avait coupé l'herbe sous le pied au
départ même de l'âge donc une obligation
de résultat non parce que il est
dépendant de de la mécanique d'un
facteur chance qu'il a rappelé également
des éléments des éléments naturels et
oui on peut considérer que lui et son
équipe ont mis tous les moyens de leur
côté pour pouvoir performer sur le sur
le
sur le sur la Route du Rhum et on
prévision en prévision justement avec
cet investissement sur ce bateau cette
reprise cette transformation pour
performer sur le Vendée Globe là il n'a
pas forcément le choix dans la date sur
le l'entraînement avec avec cette course
là mais en tout cas il a il a une
occasion de répéter et de et de montrer
que que son équipe a tenu compte des
impondérables comme la casse la casse
dont on a que l'on a rappelé et pouvoir
justement performer le mieux possible
dans la tête et puis après avec ce
facteur chance qui le mettra bien au
départ sur cette transat là et sur le
Vendée Globe Michel ténia résumé
franchement il est payé pour ça
qu'est-ce que je peux rajouter
effectivement c'est aléatoire lorsqu'on
est tributeur des éléments bon après ils
ont analysé la case Dumas bon sans
savoir exactement pourquoi après tout a
été optimisé les câbles attention la
tension des câbles etc donc avec une
équipe très performante c'est du très
très haut niveau c'est de la technologie
bon il a mis tous les moyens de son côté
il part parmi les favoris n'oublions pas
qu'il y a 130 sept bateaux au départ
voilà il est pas tout seul il sera pas
il sera pas seul voilà toute catégorie
confondues bien sûr
bon maintenant il peut gagner mais
toujours avec ce facteur chance et moi
ce qui m'impressionne voilà c'est jour
en nuit 24 heures sur 24 à la barre
voilà ce sont des grands aventuriers des
grands bonhomme c'est incroyable il a
fait troisième sur la bermud race il a
fini 5e sur la Vendée arctique il est
quand même plutôt bien placé à chaque
fois Louis il se place plutôt bien et la
Route du Rhum c'est une course aussi
dont il a l'habitude son meilleur
résultat c'est 4e 4e du rhum c'était en
2014 oui donc sur le format on se
rapproche de plus en plus du Vendée
Globe là bas voilà il sera il sera tout
seul comme sur le Vendée Globe sur la
Transat c'était un format différent il y
a cette traversée de l'Atlantique même
si on est sur un mini Vendée Globe il y
a pas de tour du monde pour le coup mais
oui il se place bien il se met petit à
petit en confiance et forcément c'est
une étape importante dans cette
préparation du Vendée Globe pierre il
faut juste une question philosophique là
maintenant c'est savoir si le si la
course au grand large ces courses là
vont être impactés par ce fameux
réchauffement climatique dont on parle
beaucoup et avec et avec finalement des
phénomènes météo qui vont qui vont sans
doute dans les années à venir impacter
ces grandes courses à travers
l'atlantiquement en tout cas de ça de la
pollution aussi un des océans ils sont
sur ce qui traîne dans les océans c'est
il témoignent beaucoup de la folie il y
a beaucoup d'abandon justement dû à des
objets flottants non identifiés ça a été
le cas sur le dernier Vendée Globe et
beaucoup beaucoup d'abandons et ce qui
avait expliqué aussi les bouleversements
classement avec ce final incroyable ou
Louis Burton fini 3e on va maintenant
parler football dans ce SOP c'est l'un
des sujets du moment qu'il y a Mbappé
peut-il quitter le PSG en janvier ou en
fin de saison plusieurs médias dont des
journaux espagnols et des médias
français ont affirmé cette hypothèse une
information démentie par le club
parisien et notamment par son entraîneur
Christophe Galtier après plusieurs jours
d'interrogations Kylian Mbappe a pris la
parole après PSG OM pour dire que ce
n'était pas vrai les affaires sont
également sorties d'après Mediapart le
PSG aurait utilisé une armée numérique
pour dénigrer plusieurs personnes du
monde du football donc il y a son propre
joueur et se sentiraient donc trahi la
question sur cette thématique Kylian
Mbappe doit-il quitter le PSG oui ou non
pour vous Pierre Chevalier oui pour vous
Grégory canalet et oui pour vous
Jean-Michel richefort on va faire un
petit duel encore entre Pierre et
Grégory
vous commencez oui bah il y a trop
d'affaires c'est-à-dire qu'au bout d'un
moment on peut dire il y a des rumeurs
qui sortent ce sont les médias espagnols
qui essayent de faire grossir l'affaire
après le non départ cette été parce que
c'est aussi l'un des feuilletons de
l'été est-ce que Kylian Mbappe quittera
ou pas le PSG on annoncé oui finalement
il est resté au Paris Saint-Germain mais
cette dernière affaire il faut faire
toute la lumière pour le moment ça reste
que une affaire qui est sorti par
Mediapart qui n'a pas été confirmée pour
l'instant le PSG botte en touche Jean
martial RIP qui était le directeur de la
communication pour le moment on n'a pas
réagi autour de cette affaire mais cette
affaire sordide ou le PSG aurait payé
une agence de communication pour
dénigrer son propre joueur en 2018 on
rappelle juste plusieurs de ses joueurs
plusieurs de ces joueurs il y a aussi
Adrien rabiot notamment dans les
victimes de cette armée numérique là
enfin on dépasse tout entendement
c'est-à-dire que au bout d'un moment il
y a tellement d'affaires qui
s'accumulent il y a eu aussi le pivot
gate le pivot game parce que il se
plaint énormément qui vient de Mbappé de
son positionnement sur le terrain et qui
prend plus de plaisir en équipe de
France avec Giroud avec Griezmann
qu'avec neymar et Messi au Paris
Saint-Germain où il n'occupent pas sa
position favorite en tout cas celle qui
est utilisée par par Christophe Galtier
non là il y a une accumulation
d'affaires qui font qu'au final je pense
qu'il devrait trouver son bonheur
ailleurs même pour lui grandir
professionnellement dans le monde du
football c'est bien aussi qu'il puisse
voir si l'herbe est plus fraîche
ailleurs et plus verte ailleurs
d'ailleurs
mais après à quel prix ça c'est aussi la
question ce qui vient de renouveler son
contrat avec le Paris Saint-Germain et
un départ de Kylian Mbappé se négociera
pas en dessous des 200 millions d'euros
donc est-ce qu'un club aujourd'hui
peut-être à part Manchester City
pourrait s'offrir ce joueur le Real
Madrid connaissez pas c'est aussi toute
la question mais pour moi il faut qu'il
quitte le PSG là il y a eu trop
d'affaires Pierre Chevalier j'étais
mitigé sur cette sur cette question mais
juste un rappel sur la formulation de la
question ou c'est plus nous ce que l'on
pense de qu'il y a Mbappé au PSG plutôt
le PSG ne se substituer à ceux qui le
pensent lui et à son avenir ceci est
ceci étant dit ou rappelé
il faut il faut également rappeler que
il tient la baraque depuis trois saisons
quasiment même si peu moins cette saison
même si voilà ce que j'allais dire même
si même si Messi et Neymar notamment
avec ce triangle ce triangle d'or
on haussé leur niveau et sont un petit
peu plus dans les dans les standards et
les critères qu'on attendait d'eux
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés à lorsqu'ils
sont arrivés à Paris donc il tient la
baraque ce qui me fait dire que pour
l'instant
mon point de vue ne doit pas quitter le
PSG c'est que on va avoir une saison
particulière à Paris c'est une saison de
Coupe du monde du monde où il va y avoir
une grande césure une grande saisure en
hiver il va presque y avoir deux
championnats on en parle notamment avec
ses valses d'entraîneur qui sont déjà en
cours en Ligue 1 ou le championnat va
redémarrer en janvier après la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar donc on a parlé dont on
reparlera peut-être voilà
donc la saison va être particulière pour
l'instant on peut peut-être espérer que
ce soit l'année ou jamais pour la Ligue
des Champions donc ne serait-ce que pour
la gagner avec Paris depuis le temps
qu'on en parle il faut qu'il faut qu'il
reste à Paris
maintenant ce qui est aussi me mettait
dans une situation un petit peu
hésitante sur la réponse à la question
c'est effectivement les affaires que
vous avez les affaires que vous avez
rappelé c'est c'est aller assez
incroyable et même jusqu'à imaginer quel
est l'intérêt si c'est si c'est avéré
quel est l'intérêt d'un club comme Paris
de de mener une une opération de sabrage
comme celle-là si ce n'est que pour
faire un fond pour faire prendre une
décision plus rapidement que plus
rapidement qu'attendu par rapport au
premier aux principales principaux
intéressés puisqu'il y a plusieurs
joueurs concernés de l'armée numérique
voilà de cette armée numérique qui est
juste qui est juste assez incroyable
j'ai même du mal à pointer l'intérêt
d'une telle cabane mais ceci étant dit
la saison va être particulière pour
l'instant elle semble être elle semble
être bien partie avec un Galtier qui est
aux manettes qui semblent avoir trouvé
des clés que les précédents n'avaient
pas forcément activé ou actionnés au
moins il a le il a l'oreille du
vestiaire et avec toutes ces stars c'est
c'est une chose qui est pas forcément
évidente et
rien que pour les premiers matchs de
Kylian Mbappe au parc de cette saison
sur la droite ligne de la saison
dernière voir la saison d'avant il a il
a il a à nouveau toutes les cartes en
main pour être le taulier du vestiaire
du vestiaire parisien ce que je trouve
que
sur ce qu'on peut voir de l'extérieur
mais Neymar ne sont sont au niveau
sportif mais pas forcément au niveau
d'influence qu'il pouvait avoir à
Barcelone tous les deux par exemple et
il a il a il a l'occasion de remporter
la Ligue des Champions peut-être après
une Coupe du Monde euphorisante même si
on a du mal à imaginer ce que ça va
donner ce que ça va donner pour l'équipe
de France mais il pourra revenir un
petit peu regonflé à bloc pour cette
deuxième partie de saison et il sera
temps de se poser la question pour la
saison d'après ou là il sera peut-être
difficile de le garder Jean-Michel Faure
effectivement doit-il rester au PSG moi
je dis non faut qu'il parte faut qu'il
parte à un moment donné à un autre alors
le plus tard sera le mieux parce que bon
on y va partir selon vous quoi qu'il
arrive quoi qu'il arrive si c'est pas
cette année ce sera l'année prochaine ça
sera forcément
je pense l'an prochain mais il partira
il partira parce que bon PSG ouais c'est
quand même particulier il
l'entourage il y a toujours des affaires
il y a toujours des des choses bon voilà
et on n'est pas concentré à 100% sur le
football tel que on aimerait on aimerait
qui on ne parle pas beaucoup de football
c'est bien dommage bon c'est une grande
équipe on souhaite tous les voir enfin
gagner cette
Ligue des Champions mais voilà on peut
en douter cela dit bon c'est un grand
joueur c'est le taulier c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui fait la différence quoi et
bien sûr que mais il faut le laisser
encore
partir où aussi on pense tous en
poussant on pense tous au Real ça aurait
été un bon choix parce que ça serait le
Real Madrid
Liverpool ou éventuellement City oui
j'attends de voir en tout cas je suis
impatient de voir le début de la Coupe
du monde pour dans quel état d'esprit va
l'aborder alors pour le moment ça sent
pas latin dans ses affaires là il est
sorti de son match face à Marseille il a
tout de suite il est tout de suite venu
à la presse ça ressemble quand même une
opération de de communication
on sent qu'il y a quand même un peu de
langue de bois dans ce qu'il dit qu'il
ne croit pas enfin il fait confiance à
son club qu'il ne croit pas en cette
information sur sur l'armée numérique il
n'a jamais voulu quitter aussi le Paris
Saint-Germain ça ressemble quand même
voilà une opération de com on essaie de
de désamorcer les choses mais moi j'ai
hâte de voir comment il va se placer
dans cette Coupe du monde et ce qui va
être en totale confiance totalement
libérée de toutes les affaires extra
sportives parce qu'il y a aussi un
conflit en équipe de France sur le
sponsoring il y a eu des refus de sa
part de participer à des séances photos
parce que il jugeait que les sponsors en
question parlent de sponsor notamment de
de restauration rapide n'était pas
adapté à son image il y a tout un tas de
petites affaires PSG équipe de France
est-ce que il va être dans les
meilleures conditions à la Coupe du
Monde ou en plus l'équipe de France va
aborder cette condition peut être avec
des absences de le poids Ngolo Kanté
forcément en premier lieu ça reste à
démontrer un génie gérer un génie c'est
à ce prix là
cette émission ça sera le mot de la fin
avec vous Grégory c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission on va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
je vous propose une citation de la
légende le King
Eric Cantona les Anglais ont inventé le
foot les Français l'ont t'organisé les
Italiens le mettent en scène je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]